this program is being presented to you
by the Harris International winter
school on gravity and lights so welcome
to lecture 15 of the winter school we
now have all the important technology
collected in order to talk about
Einstein gravity now recall that in
Newtonian space-time which we talked
about in lecture nine we were able to
reformulate it's just a reformulation
it's not new physics we were able to
reformulate the warsaw law that the
Dalembert ssin of the gravitational
potential is four pi Rho where Rho is
the matter density that produces the
gravitational potential we were able to
reformulate the poisson law in terms of
the Newtonian space-time curvature
as our zero zero it was two zero zero
component of the Ricci tensor with
respect to the Newtonian connection that
we identified and that was 4 PI R oh
sorry there's a G and missing G sub N
and his G sub n ro and Reap sub n in
general here is the Newtonian
gravitational constant
that's for instance the one you measure
in this Cavendish experiment with the
two big balls okay so we're able to
reformulate the personal like this now
this was in Newtonian space-time and
however relations of this form prompted
Einstein this prompted Einstein of
course Einstein thought about this in
many different ways so it's difficult to
say what exactly prompted him to do what
in the course of the development of the
theory but roughly speaking this
prompted Einstein to postulate in the
years before 1915 I'm not exactly sure
when he wrote this down maybe 1912 or so
that the relativistic field equations
for the Lorentzian metric for the
Laurentian metric v of space-time as we
define it this morning of relativistic
space-time if you want to put emphasis
on it it prompted him to postulate that
the relativistic field equations ought
to be Rab equal 8 pi G Newton GA be the
8 has to do with the conventions for the
factors now so it's R 0 0 is Rho and R 0
0 s again connected with the energy
density we saw that you will go to the 0
0 component with respect to some
observer you get something like this but
then this split that 0 0 is special has
to do with the absolute time and I said
well we don't want that we don't want
that direction to be special so it ought
to look like this however this equation
suffers from a problem and the problem
is that the right-hand side if you raise
the indices and so on by the way so I'm
now using a lot lots of indices so I
seem to be in a chart all the time and
yeah you can view it like that if you
know what you're doing it's perfectly
fine to be in a chart but you can also
look at this like this is not in a chart
at all that would be Penrose as for you
a quick way of writing what you want to
say ok anyway so we take the view you're
in some chart but it's true in all the
charts so who cares right this is just
much quicker notation than if I wrote
everything chart independent the point
the important point is it is chart
independent what I write down you could
check it explicitly ok anyway so if you
take on the right hand side this
divergence over the first index of this
tensor and we know from the meta theory
that this yields 0 this has to do with
the fact that the matter theory has been
formulated from an action and this
action was formulated without or could
have been formulated without the choice
of coordinates and that yields you this
kind of conservation law
now that's the right hand side now on
the left hand side you have a different
situation if you take the derivative of
the I stand tensor and then you contract
over these two oh sorry I sentence of
the Ricci tensor this is Ritchie right
the RIC guy I can write it like this
because here you see it's really not
Riemann
this is not zero generically it might in
certain situations it might be zero but
generically it isn't now that's not good
for an equation because obviously I
could take this divergence on both sides
and it leads to a contradiction and so
what do you do so Einstein try to argue
this problem away gravity is different
you know you all don't understand but
nevertheless it's wrong
nevertheless the equations cannot be
upheld so those are not the field
equations now what is the solution to
this well the solution came back
Einstein but at the same time by Hilbert
Hilbert as you all know one of the most
famous mathematicians of all time he was
actually a specialist for variational
principles
for variational principles and he
recognized that this is because this
comes from an action so he thought why
not derive the left-hand side also from
an action so Hilbert suggested to solve
or to find the appropriate left-hand
side of the field equations of the
gravitational field equations Hilbert
suggested to start from a variational
principle from an action and so s
Hilbert he said why don't we write down
an action for the G it's a field theory
so it must be over the entire manifold
well what is the simplest function I
could make of the metric well I could
contract it with itself that's the
dimension it's a very boring function
actually them from Riemannian geometry
one knows that the simplest function one
can build from the metric it's first the
second derivatives is are from the first
derivatives you can't build any tensor
and from the second derivatives you can
build the Ricci scalar which you
remember is our a B G a B it's the
simplest function but of course if you
integrate a function over a manifold you
need to have a density here in order to
make the whole thing work so by the
rather obscure principle of simplicity
simplest action one might arrive at
something like this now of course you
can talk about the beauty of equations I
can talk about the simplicity of
equations the equation being economical
and two shortest in whatever equation
all of these are aesthetic arguments
that have nothing to do with physics
right
if physics for aesthetics planets would
run on circles and not on ellipses
because the circle is more perfect than
the ellipses right so so it's obvious
this is not a good guiding principle on
the other hand if you're a mathematician
can say oh these physicists they're just
writing down equations just like that
and they get inconsistencies well let's
see what I can get if I start with the
simplest here maybe I get some insight
on how this left-hand side must look
like so that's roughly the idea now in
the following many people for many years
have thought about how to justify the
Einstein equations further and I will
probably talk about this at the end of
the course where if time permits I will
also explain that this action is the
unique one you can write down if you
want to have Maxwell theory on it and
that makes your theory ought to be
predictive and quantized about but
anyway that will be later if time
permits
so we start here this is what Hilbert
just wrote down in order to write down
something he could vary ok so well
that's essentially that's a fair
statement right I mean anything else is
interpreting something into it which
isn't really in them now so this is
Hilbert's suggestion and the aim is
varying this with respect to the metric
G a B would will result in some tensor
that one can show abstractly that if you
vary such a scalar function with respect
to a tensor it will result in it in some
tensor G up a B
okay and if there's nothing else to it
it would be G up a B equals zero because
we didn't add a matter action you would
get something like this and the question
is what is this tensor capital G that we
get out of the variation of this with
respect to the metric well there's only
one way to find out
so variation of a Silbert we do it okay
now you know variation leads to the
Euler Lagrange equations if you don't
specify the Lagrangian then you get very
general equations you can work them out
using it's quicker to vary a new rather
than writing down the Euler Lagrange
equations but you just do the variation
again now variation if you really write
it down for point particles involves
deforming curves and so on yet you
involves deforming fields and but there
is a quick way to determine the
variation by just some symbolic calculus
and you probably saw all of this before
I just do it again in this quick way
because this is really very useful okay
for a proper mathematical foundation you
look at any book that does that properly
but but what I do is write it's just at
some point have to say well variation
behaves like differentiation which it
actually does okay so we varied the
action it's understood that the
variation is with respect to the metric
okay okay and we require that the
variation vanish and that ought to give
us the field equations now what is the
variation of s Hilbert the variation of
s Hilbert is the following M so now we
have in here
the square root of minus the determinant
of G we have in there the G a B that
contracts and the Rab that depends on
the G its first and second derivatives
no this is if I vary this action the
variation of this will yield a tensor G
a B now if I add it to your plus s
matter I would then get on the
right-hand side a ta B and I have two
field equations it's just that I denote
the variation of this action by G a B I
already wrote the equal to zero if you
add nothing else that's the vacuum field
equations so maybe I should say varying
this with respect will result in some
tensor G a B is probably better the
better statement okay
so follows because in the action if you
formulate this chart free-trading it
shot independent you can actually show
that this implies a notice theorem that
gives you that that that's the point so
this can really be shown from there okay
so you very well you have to vary this
this in this so the variation is like a
derivative well that's the first of
these rules so it varies the first
factor plus it varies the second factor
and keeps the others plus it keeps the
first and the second and it varies the
last factor this is what variation does
have you seen stuff like this before in
classical mechanics probably yes ok so
here it's done for fields but it works
very similarly okay
so obviously we have to solve three
little problems the first one is we need
to find what is the variation of the
square root of minus the determinant of
G what is the variation of the inverse
metric rather than the metric and what's
the variation of the Ricci tensor well
let's do this one by one so let's call
this term one term to return three we
need to get them under control one after
the other
okay so at one
the variation of the square root of
minus G essentially it's a derivative is
first you get rid you of the outer
derivative and out here you have minus
and the derivative of a determinant is
the determinant itself times okay I
should write determined to be clear it's
the determinant itself times the inverse
of the matrix of which you take the
determinant that's this one times the
variation actually looking at that's
this okay right so how can you see this
so in here goes that variation of the
determinant G is the determinant of G
times G M and Delta G MN how do you see
this eg from and are going through this
the fact that the determinant of G is
the X of the trace of the Ln of G this
is one one way to look at that okay so
you get this and we have this here the
result is 1/2 square root of minus g GM
n Delta G MN this is the first lemma we
have then at 2 you have the variation of
the inverse metric well how do you get
this well if you have G a B and you have
g pc you know this is Delta AC that's
clear so therefore now varying on both
sides and if here the product rule delta
g a b x gb c + g a b delta g bc equals 0
applied the variation to both sides but
then i can isolate this by pulling the g
to the other side this gives you Delta G
a B
equals minus G am G P and Delta G MN and
I renamed indices in the last line to
make the result look more memorable okay
so it's the second little result we're
going to use here now before we do this
let me do the third here there
essentially we have to figure out what
is the variation of the Ricci tensor now
this is more tricky nevertheless we're
able to do it with our technology now
the Ricci tensor if I go to normal
coordinates at a point I can consider
the variation at the point you go to
normal coordinates the Ricci tensor it's
the partial Gama so it should be D by DX
whatever I write down I write this in
short form like this M a M comma B minus
del gamma M a B M and normally you would
have plus gamma gamma minus gamma gamma
with certain contractions right you saw
this but because we're in normal
coordinates these go out the derivatives
remain because normal ones are just at
the point so the next point it could be
different but these guys go but now we
take the variation of this with the
Delta of this and the Delta of that
now the next step consists in observing
and in fact I can formulate this here's
a nice rule that these guys commute but
how do you know this is right well you
have to formulate the variation more
properly if you do you see it does
commute yes
pammi yeah before I very yes because
variation means you choose two different
gammas yes yes and so then you get here
minus del M Delta Gamma M ay B well even
if you didn't look sub sub sub Julian
Julian even if you didn't do this before
wearing you would here have a delta
gamma gamma that would be a delta gamma
times gamma plus a Gamma Delta Gamma
here minus Delta gamma gamma minus gamma
delta gamma you agree still at the end
there still one gamma in there that
moves this okay so you go to this line
here and now there's an important
observation the Delta is the difference
between two gammas because I take a
gamma and I compared to another gamma
now it's a fact of life that if you have
one gamma gamma IJ K and I subtracted
from a totally different gamma different
choice of gammas a different different
connection coefficients ijk both uses
back to the same chart that this are the
components components of a one two
tensor why is that well because on the
corner transformations this guy picks up
an ugly term it transforms as a tensor
up to an ugly term but the ugly term
doesn't depend on the gamma at all it
depends only on the change of coordinate
system remember divided by the X t2 x by
d YY this one also changes in its linear
term like this takes a tensor term this
contributes and the extra term is
exactly the same but you subtract so the
extra terms cancel hence
the difference between two connection
coefficients two different choices of
connection is a tensor two connections
differ by a tensor now this is important
here because we're still in normal
coordinates we've chosen them once and
for all for this calculation so if the
difference here is the tensor and this
is a tensor then in normal coordinates I
have this del B and you say oh my god I
can't derive tensor components like this
well the point is you can take this
tensor and you can even make of the
partial derivative or covariant
derivative without harm because the
difference between the covariant and
partial derivative is gamma terms right
but the gamma terms all vanish because
we do normal coordinates so I can write
it like this I mean this is rather
remarkable I mean there's a gamma which
usually can't take a covariant
derivative of because this is not a
tensor but we see there's a tensor so we
can do all this game in normal
coordinates
- nabla M Delta Gamma components M a B
aha so now we did this and at that point
we can't make any further progress until
we realize ah but there is not this term
interesting interesting is this entire
term so let's try to figure that one out
so hence it follows the square root of
minus G G a B Delta R a B equals aha so
square root of minus 3 now this G a B is
actually in front of this right but I
can without harm pull it into this and I
should introduce some notation that is
very useful notation if you have a
tensor say one one tensor and you take
its derivative in the B direction and
you have an I in a J then this from now
on sometimes I will write a
i J semicolon B a semicolon says take
the covariant derivative in Direction B
but don't think you take the covariant
derivative of the components the symbol
means take the covariant derivative of
the tensor and then that's the component
from the tensor out here okay very
important so I could write this guy here
as Delta Gamma M a MC me : b and here
Delta Gamma M ay B semicolon M okay so
now I use this here I go maybe a line
you know equals square root minus G now
I can certainly pull this G into the
semicolon why well because it's the
metric compatible connection so G a B
Delta Gamma ma m semicolon around it be
Y well it will satisfy a product rule it
will take the covariant derivative of
the G times this guy plus G times the
covalent derivative of that guy but the
covalent derivative of G or G inverse is
zero because of nebula G equals zero
okay so you can pull this in without
harm that's the stress term minus square
root of minus G G a B gamma delta gamma
importantly M a B in brackets semi-colon
M ah that looks much better why does it
look better because if you look at this
here this index M summed over this index
a is summed over all that's left here is
an index B in here which is then being
arrived but because this is a tensor
this is being summed over in here our
vector components so I say I can
identify that there's a vector a with
components B and the vector is
covalently derived with respect to B
minus
square root of minnows - gee this is a
different vector because here gamma ma
vie there's the a side and the B some
that's a different vector from this one
is called the vector B up em semicolon
em aha
why is this interesting well this is the
divergence of a vector this is their
versions of another vector but
remarkably because this is summed over
you can check that this is the same as
if I did square root of - gee I took the
ad and I take the partial derivative in
Direction B yields the same result
because the corrections that come from
here are actually Corrections that come
here by application of the product rule
minus square root of minus G B B
semicolon P or mmm doesn't matter okay
yes
so a gamma in the white system ijk is
the gamma in an ex parte m and Q with D
by D D by D D by D X in X Y hang on
there must be a why I here No so there
must be why I XM x and x q YJ YK is that
right yes plus D 2 X M by dy j dy k dy
by DX M a PI
isn't that the right term okay so this
is for this connection gamma now I write
this down for an entirely different
connection in the same frame what I get
is exactly the same terms here but here
there's a gamma twiddle m and Q in the X
frame but this term is precisely the
same because there's no gamma appearing
now the difference between the true will
transform without return because they
cancel
okay good yes a and B are tensors as you
can read off from here they are the
tenses defined here this is the a B and
this is the p.m. well look at it it's a
it's as tensor component it's a delta
gamma what do you mean oh it is so you
have a delta gamma as a tensor it has
components MA
b-but you have a contraction here that
makes it a co vector field or a co
vector then you pull the index up it's a
product of tensors to contract the
tensor product it's a tensor how you get
from here to here yes
oh that the comma I am sorry that the
comma is the partial derivative so I
panic semicolon semicolon is I'm sorry
only comma comma as partial okay and
then you have a product and the partial
goes on this guy and this guy will
reproduce itself but also produce the
gamma symbol that goes with the a not
the full gamma symbol but the right
contracted gamma symbol okay yes yeah
okay um well if you derive if you vary X
you get X / trace LNG that Tribute
reproduces the determinant again but
then you have to take the inner
derivative and the inner derivative of
Ln is 1 over that's the inverse okay so
now if you want to have it more
precisely written down the cleanest
proof is via the expansion formula for
the determinant when you expand in a
line with the minors or the drunks or
whatever that's called where you cross
the eyes in the Jade line and take the
determinant tralala and there you can in
a one-page calculation or so you arrive
at this formula okay so this is the
quick way I don't want to go into the
detail here right so this can be shown
okay so we have collected the terms one
two
and three and it's time to write this up
collecting terms one obtains zero is
Delta s hilbert equals M now the
variation of the square root of minus G
was one-half minus square root of G G MN
Delta G MN right then was the first term
which came with another G a B Rab that's
the first term plus now there comes
another square root of minus G now
variation of the inverse metric yields a
minus G a m GP n Delta G MN and came
with an R a B that's the next term the
third term comes to the plus square root
of minus G G a B but now this variation
over there which I need to quickly pick
that before it's wiped out oh yeah okay
thank you times aha I already use this
up right in this over there I don't need
to write this anymore because I already
included all of this this becomes square
root of minus G some vector a I'm not
interested how it looks in detail comma
a minus minus G some vector E
I'm not even interest how it looks in
Gita comma B close bracket
okay that's this so now you have an
integral over volume and what kind of
Armistice if you have the derivative
here and it's contracted like this is it
divergence right and yes exactly Stoke
or whatever so it's a surface term and
this is also a surface term so if you're
not very careful you say you can discard
them they're zero if there's no boundary
well you see in point particle mechanics
you fix two endpoints and then you do
this variation and you take care that at
the endpoints things are fixed if you
want to do this shield Theory
calculation properly you have to fix an
initial surface in the final surface and
you need to fix the fields there and
varied them in between and then if you
want to do this properly you also fix
them on the boundaries here right and
then maybe you take the boundary to
infinity and so on that's somewhat
subtle okay so in the action there may
be surface terms that survive if you
want to have the action as the axis the
value of the action however for the
equations of motions they really don't
make a difference so we can take them
out for the equations of motion okay
that's it okay so we do that but that
what we are we left with
M we can factor out the minus square
root or the square root of minus G we
can factor out the variation the
arbitrary vation Delta variation Delta G
MN and what we end up with is 1/2 G em
up em n R because this is our minus this
as
this is put up rmn equal to zero for an
arbitrary variation because that
variation is arbitrary we can conclude
from the vanishing the integral for an
arbitrary variation the square bracket
must vanish
hence we obtain that our tensor gmm
equals well I should have said that the
stencil that comes out is called minus G
MN okay I mean I didn't make a sign
mistake so it's just a question of how I
call this guy BM n equals I should have
written minus G MN before when I said
Hilbert wants to derive this and then
you get our MN minus 1/2 g MN our that
is what Hilbert gets out so hence
Hilbert from this mathematical argument
one might call it from this mathematical
argument concluded that one may take our
a be minus 1/2 G a B R which is just the
same object with the indices pulled down
with the metric equals 8 pi G and T a B
and in fact Einstein by physical
arguments arrived at the same result
more or less at the same time so these
are the these are called the Einstein
equations Hilbert is not mentioned but
the action that I called Hilbert hot
today called the Einstein Hilbert
and I think everybody agrees that does
both of them justice because Einstein
came here by physical arguments again
and well Hilbert just in a sense scooped
Einstein by listening to one of his
talks hearing about this problem saying
let's try this and doing this little
calculation okay
so um these are the equations on which
general relativity today is based now
still there is at this point no better
argument for this than saying this is a
pretty nice compact action right so one
can of course argue whether that's a
good reason for a physicist or not okay
so then we have a third solution of the
novella a ta P equals zero issue one
control in fact you will show in the
tutorials that this so-called Einstein
curvature that the Einstein curvature
which is this zero two tensor G a B
equals R AP minus one-half G a B are
exactly the left hand side of the
Einstein equations that this Einstein
curvature satisfies the so called that's
just the name that you find in the books
on this named contracted contracted by
Yankee identic differential contracted
differential by Yankee identity
you wouldn't have guessed it this equals
zero okay so the issue is indeed solved
and it had to be solved because this was
derived from an action where the same
argument that leads to the nabla a to
the divergence of the energy momentum
tensor being zero that was your question
the same argument leads to that this
must hold if this didn't hold then
somebody somewhere made a mistake okay
yes so this dissolves this argument and
it shows well Einstein really forgot
this term and this is a term that comes
up by this consistency argument okay
yes well there are a number and over the
years people so instance you can look at
at fluids and so you can feel space-time
with the fluid and one understands kind
of worry and at the time one understood
relativistic two it's how do they behave
and that you can then make consistency
arguments and you pick up this term okay
there are many other ways by which you
can arrive here a way that's that's a
recent result how you arrived there is
you require that you have dynamics for
your space-time that is compatible with
putting Maxwell theory on it such that
the Mexica theory remains predictive and
is quantized able and that already fixes
the Einstein equations as I said at the
end of the talk there school I will talk
about this yes
the in the Newtonian space-time which is
zero me in no no you can't even
construct it because in the Newtonian
space-time the Newtonian space-time only
carries a connection but this connection
does not derive from a metric on
Newtonian space-time it's a connection
that doesn't come from a metric and if
you don't have a metric you cannot
construct the curvature scalar because
from a connection you get the Riemann
tensor 1 3 and from that you get by
contraction of 1 and 3 you get the Ricci
tensor that you get from a connection
but you don't get these two indices away
unless you have a metric in the game as
well but there is no MIT connection so
Newtonian space-time we only talked
about ultra power less and if you
remember I presented in Newtonian
picture before we introduced metrics
because I didn't want you to get
confused to the Newtonian space-time
that love so the neuter did so the
Newtonian space-time carries only a
connection but not a metric so you
couldn't even build this guy and in your
own space-time we only found that the
zero zero component of this guy is this
4 pi zero right but I could not even say
and all the others are 0 but I couldn't
even say what the scalar was ok
so this heavily relies on the fact that
all the connection that these curvature
tensors are built from the levy shemitah
connection of the gene these are the
metric curvatures for the question
yes no they do not
we I'll discuss the cosmological
constant a second they do not they do
not know they they do not these guys I
don't know but the issue is that if you
go to these surfaces like like here you
can fix the points and you can fix but
you cannot fix the velocities at the
same time now there this guy here the
the hill but actually depends on the
metric up to the second derivative and
some issues CR you can't fix the second
derivatives as well you can fix the
metric and the frill and so on and so
you have to discuss this very carefully
what happens at the boundaries that's
the point
okay and this was only discovered later
that you have to do this so I think
Gibbons and others say they looked at
this at these boundary terms and they
play a role in the canonical formulation
that too many could rule any is going to
discuss one of the satellite like for us
there one usually takes good care of
these guys one needs them but for the
equations of motion they really drop out
okay so they only play a role in the
absolute value of the action not for the
equations of motion okay so then we
finally look at variance of the field
equations
and I don't need variants like other
gravitational theories I mean the same
field equations a little extended or a
little differently written down so the
first one is a simple rewriting and
resemble your writings the following so
let's again write down the field
equations I mean this you need to know
by heart this is the key point of this
course 8 pi G in T a B now maybe for the
future just for the heck of it we will
set this to 1 over 8 pi so that I can
finally get rid of these annoying
factors right and in fact I think
there's always one over C squared in
there which I already set to 1 and so
who cares okay so I'm let's assume these
are the field equations right so aha
so now I can on both sides contract with
G a B I do a full contraction what do I
get
what is RA be fully contracted with G a
B R what is G a be contracted with G a B
4 thank you dimension of space time for
a half is 2r minus 2r equals T where T
is defined as T a B G a B ok so now
therefore I have R minus 2 s minus R R
is minus T agree so I go with this into
the original field equations I have RA
be minus 1/2 G a B T with a plus equals
T a B or RA B equals T a be minus 1/2
its trace G a B so I can call this
right-hand side the modified energy
momentum tensor
at a B we're from the energy moment sir
I subtract 1/2 times its trace so
contraction with G times G a B and what
do I then have then the Einstein field
equations after all take to form our a B
equals T hat a be science M wasn't that
wrong after all he just took the wrong
version of the energy-momentum tensor
there's an energy momentum tensor with a
modified trait
okay but of course he had to no longer t
hat a B equals zero right it's just a
simple rewriting so if you wish you can
relate the Ricci curvature directly to
an energy momentum tensor well a
modified energy momentum tensor ok so
sometimes it's useful to write it like
this it's just a simple conclusion from
the field equations themselves ok and
the second variant is indeed different
physics and the second variant is if you
do the Einstein Hilbert action M square
root minus G R and in here you write
plus 2 capital lambda and now this
capital lambda has a name
called the cosmological constant and
it's nothing mysterious it's just a
constant that you add
well let's interpret this in a second
but before that let's look at the
history of this cosmological constant so
1915 right
I think Einstein said it must be there
and since it because more logical
constant is there and it's less than
zero
Einstein wanted that why because only if
you put that there do you get solutions
for cosmology for the history of all of
space-time that produces a static
universe in order to get a non expanding
universe because - I understand at the
time it seemed ridiculous that the
universe should be expanding instead of
just be sitting there so he wanted this
constant then later of course Hubble saw
the universe is expanding which is
perfectly compatible with lambda equals
zero so Einstein said this was my
greatest blunder I shouldn't have done
that
this is an aesthetical and nando tutor
and he said lambda equals zero I mean no
doubt there many papers what lambda must
be zero okay so now today lambda is
supposed to be bigger than zero
now it's supposed to be bigger than zero
in order to account for to account for
and we'll see this in detail I'm just
giving you the taste of it to account
for an accelerated expansion so the
universe doesn't only expand it expands
in an accelerated way an accelerated
expansion today the problem is that this
lambda it is supposed to be bigger than
zero but
very very small okay what do you mean by
very small well very small compared to
any effect we could imagine that
produces a non-vanishing lambda let me
clarify this so if we now do here the
variation the lambda contribution here
can of course be understood as a
contribution to matter right because if
you say this is still gravity then this
part could already belong to a matter
action right so lambda non zero can be
interpreted interpreted as a
contribution what is it I think my 1/2 1
minus 1/2 lambda G a B 2 the energy
momentum of matter in space-time
okay okay why not well look at what that
means that means constantly overall the
universe there is a lambda that is
energy everywhere provided by the lambda
it's not just where the fields are big
over the fields are non vanishing it
everywhere everywhere where there is a
metric and a metric is everywhere there
is this energy and so people call this
dark energy it doesn't interact with
anything but it contributes to a
curvature of space-time that means it's
dark yes
um one one can as I said one can
carefully treat this for instance so um
for a careful treatment for a careful
treatment of the surface terms which we
discarded see for instance Eric Poisson
a relativists toolkit excellent book I
think Cambridge University Press
but the point is this is at the level of
the equations of motion where you
identify this so it couldn't come from
the surface terms the surface terms are
the action level this is the level of
the equations of motion now this lambda
what could give rise to an energy that's
everywhere and we haven't thought of
before well yes well a cone if you
calculate the volume of the sphere you
integrate over the function constant one
right so volume of the sphere
now you take capital lambda times two
volume you can pull it out of the
integral times 1 so it's lambda times
the volume of space-time in the action
and then you have to vary okay
you can write this there it doesn't
destroy the by Anki identity and the
question is what could this physically
be we haven't thought of it so far
it seems to be there and then people
like Weinberg got the idea it could be
the vacuum fluctuations of quantum
fields so we have a number of quantum
fields in space-time now they have
vacuum fluctuations right electrons and
positrons come into his existence and
annihilate each other again right it
could be this this vacuum energy and
then Weinberg calculated the vacuum
energy I think from QCD and how it would
contribute to this lambda and would
whether it would suffice and so you can
get the following calculations for idea
lambda could come or could arise as the
vacuum energy of the standard model
fields so this is throwing in a little
bit of quantum electrodynamics but it's
quite reasonable to try that and then
you obtain lambda calculated this way is
a whopping 10 to the 100 times bigger
than the lambda observed and this is
called the worst observation of physics
the first predict the were not the worst
observations the worst prediction of
physics right so indeed we have an idea
what the mechanism could be but it
overestimates by a factor 10 to the 120
so that shows that if people say it's
not understood why we have a positive so
small positive cosmological constant
right it's a puzzle where that comes
from
if you put it there phenomenologically
it fits the observations about the
universe
we'll come to that later okay so um let
me wrap it up here in the tutorials of
this week there won't be a central
lecture until Saturday so that you can
fully focus on the satellite lecturers
we've got great people so you should
definitely come but in the tutorials
they will run on the central lecture you
will check that the so called SWAT
shield metric you must have heard that
the so called swirled
SWAT shield metric is this fairly
symmetric solution of Einstein's
equations in vacuum and Einstein
actually wrote when he set up TIG and
she said well this equations are so
complicated nobody will ever find an
exact solution okay approximately yes
linearized solutions yes but exactly no
and then Schwartz sure in 1916 the
legend the legend has it that he was
even injured and was on a hospital bed
so maybe a voice helps me today with
other research he actually said well
let's make a symmetry and that so he
derived the exact virtual solution for
under the spherically symmetric
assumptions you will check that the
Schwarzschild metric and the metric
that's called as the Friedman
robertson-walker metric that describes a
homogeneous and isotropic universe and
that P P wave metric which describe P P
waves as you can imagine and that the
Reisner nordstrom metric which describes
the therapy symmetric solution of
Einstein's equations around a charged
body and that all of these you will
check that all of these are solutions to
Einstein's equations
that means you will be asked well in
groups there will be the advanced
tutorials so this will be what we called
workshops or advanced tutorials of
physics applications what not has
different names there you will check one
group will check this the other this the
other this the other that okay and you
will work in teams of three and you must
it doesn't matter which one you check
will tell you anyway but you need to
have done this once you get a specific
metric and you plug them into the
equations it gives you the same insight
like in high school when you see
something like what is it is it like
this is like that it's like this who
knows okay plus it must be a plus okay
if you see for the first time the that
this is solved by X of T equals cos
Omega T right or sine of C what this
fight by by a function like that that's
funny
well you know it works like that okay so
it's the same thing and you must plug it
in once and then you know how this works
then you really have a feeling for what
it means to be a solution okay
that's that's one thing you're going to
do another thing you're going to do is
you're going to discuss this in advanced
tutorials in the elementary tutorials
that's the tutorials you had so far for
the mathematical foundations there you
will in the familiar manner you will
study motion of particles and observers
in for chilled space-time
okay that's a very interesting topic and
it will lead to results that will be
needed in lensing and then there will be
satellite lectures during the week
during this week next week there two
others the first ones will be by Marcus
Savannah who also give a history Club
which will be very interesting and
Marcus will talk about gravitational
lensing a tional lensing and I think he
will show things like you see if you
have a body here there is a star here
and you look here you know light goes
out in all direction and is spent here
which is by the way something you will
study on Thursday in the advanced
tutorial as well as the first advanced
tutorial signal vans tutorial you study
here at the bending the bending of light
then you know you eat a star here or you
think you see one you see one here you
see two pictures and markers sure under
which circumstances you see always an
odd number of pictures and he will show
that with Moss theory that's quite
interesting and we have too many code
aleni
many could Giulini and I asked him to
show something very important namely
actually what are the Einstein equations
the dynamical equation it seems like
boom space-time is there you solve the
equations and you have all of space-time
but where's the evolution and he will
show that very roughly speaking if you
think of the three metric in some space
that the Einstein equations tell you how
the three dimensional metric you can go
back to a spatial surface how that's
devolves in space-time and what this
requires is to reformulate the Einstein
equations in Hamiltonian form and so
that's called canonical formulation of
gravity and that gives you a lot of
insights so it's also very important and
you should really look at that and that
also has been followed for many many
years in order to make progress in
quantum gravity just the key to
quantum gravity if you want to go there
so I invite you to all these to the
elementary tutorials of course to
practice the stuff we did here to the
advanced tutorials to get a feeling for
the physics you do going to do this and
you're going to study this and also the
precession of the orbit of mercury how
it goes around the Sun rather like this
and you calculate this this here goes at
four arc seconds per century no 42 but
something acts seconds what is it 44 I
mean 42 42 arc seconds per century this
precession this was long known before
Einstein and said was the first one to
explain this and you will derive this
result from data using Einstein's theory
so I invite you to all these parts of
the school this week thank you very much